well I definitely watch some enta and I
do i do pieces for the tonight show with
jay leno and i love the writers over
there but i do have to say that it was
that that jay leno just demonstrated
remarkable readiness and grit and yeah i
mean he you know he's never been a
critical darling but my goodness that
was quite a feat I don't think that the
shows that were working without writers
could have sustained themselves for much
longer I think they simply would have
become exhausted I think there was sort
of an all-hands-on-deck kind of
emergency measure taken at a lot of
these shows I know in the case of a
couple I happen to know that and so I
don't think they could have sustained
their their quality for much longer
without a writing staff and but but
certainly the late night shows the
reputation of writers visa V the late
night shows were the most precarious
because those shows went on and didn't
lose a lot of yours